It was a beautiful day in Sardinia, the second-largest
Italian island in the Mediterranean.
The sea was clear, the air was hot, and the
beaches were golden.
But the Cagliari Diving Club couldn’t see
any of that, they were roughly 250 meters
underneath the mediterranean sea.
Given the rich and extensive history of the
area, they were sure to find some interesting
historical artifacts on the ocean floor.
And they were indeed about to find something
incredible, but this history wasn’t quite
as dead as some old Roman pottery.
Paolo Bonacelli, the most experienced diver,
was the deepest of all.
They’d decided to be a little more ambitious
this time than in previous dives - twenty
miles off the Sardinian coast.
For Paolo, it was uncharted territory, so
you could only imagine how amazed and delighted
he was when he saw the shape of what seemed
like a small town beneath the water.
Old, stone buildings in a classic Roman or
Grecian style, with roofs made of thatched
seaweed.
He gestured to his fellow divers to follow
him.
They were amazed at how well-preserved the
buildings seemed to be, as though they were
still being lived in and actively maintained
to this day, despite being around 300 meters
underwater.
If they were able to take some pictures and
collect some artifacts, they’d be the talk
of the local historic community, and probably
be able to finagle a payout from the whole
experience, too.
That’s when Paolo spotted something truly
amazing: A larger, more impressive structure,
like a miniature palace, surrounded by grandiose
statues of humanoid figures in a circle around
the little palace.
Each of the statues was an imposing five meters
tall, with a faint, golden light emanating
from each of them.
While the statues were humanoid, they definitely
weren’t human.
Their features were strange and fish-like:
Scales, gills, tentacles.
Paolo was in awe at the sight of them.
He took pictures and got closer.
There was also a huge chasm in front of the
building, perhaps some kind of underwater
thermal vent.
Paolo was curious; he wanted to investigate
further.
He swam deeper and deeper.
What was at the bottom of that chasm?
But lucky for Paolo, he would never see what
was at the bottom of that chasm.
Before he could reach it, something intercepted
him from the side.
Something large and fast.
He felt a white-hot flash of pain as claws
raked across his chest, tearing open the rubber
of his wetsuit.
Paulo turned, eyes widening in horror, to
see a creature staring at him.
Like the statues, it was humanoid but not
human.
An anthropomorphic sea monster with greenish
skin, its arms and legs coated in thin scales,
its neck serrated into fleshy gills.
He could see scraps of his suit’s rubber
hanging from its claws.
It bore a mouthful of fangs and gave a silent
but threatening snarl.
Paolo could see something in the distance
behind this creature: More figures, like this
one, emerging from the murk.
Getting faster.
Getting closer.
Paolo was a smart man, but it didn’t take
a genius to realize that if he stuck around,
something terrible was about to happen to
him and the rest of the Cagliari Diving Club.
He turned and fled, paddling with all his
might away from the coming legion of aquatic
beasts.
The rest of the club saw the experienced diver
panicking and followed his lead.
Thanks to their quick thinking and expertise,
they all managed to escape with their lives
and only a few minor injuries.
But they had no idea of the true extent of
the mystery they were leaving behind beneath
the sea.
The Multiverse is a big place.
There are alternate universes where the Devourer
of Worlds escapes and destroys everything
we love and hold dear.
There are alternate universes where the SCP
Foundation has gone haywire and attempted
to wipe out humanity through controlled releases
of all of their anomalies.
There are even universes where a kill-squad
sent by the Chaos Insurgency hunts down and
assassinates every member of the O5 Council,
before replacing them and leading the Foundation
into a bold new era.
And there are some universes where the SCP
Foundation is Italian.
We’ve covered SCP-057 on this channel before
in our video on the most frightening rooms
in the SCP universe, but you’ve never seen
this SCP-057, because this is the Italian
version: SCP-057-IT.
This localized anomaly off the coast of Sardinia
is under the purview of the Italian division
of the SCP Foundation, which works autonomously
with its own systems and terminology.
This SCP isn’t a frightening room that crushes
its trapped victims together, this anomaly
is an entire city 300 meters beneath the water
of the Mediterranean Sea.
Everyone has heard of the mythical lost city
of Atlantis, a supposed underwater utopia
outlined by such great historical minds as
the Ancient Greek philosopher Plato.
It’s something that people fantasize about:
A beautiful, idyllic society under the sea,
divorced from all the petty squabbles we deal
with up on land.
But is everything really better down where
it’s wetter?
Let’s take a look and see.
When Paolo and the rest of the Cagliari Diving
Club returned to the surface, they were happy
to tell anyone that would listen that they’d
encountered aggressive mermen and an entire
underwater city off the coast of Sardinia.
They even posted their photos onto their official
Facebook page, along with photos of Paulo’s
gnarly chest scars.
That’s when the Italian branch of the SCP
Foundation finally discovered them and decided
to intervene.
The Foundation dispatched an SIR squad known
as Aureæ Notitiæ.
SIRs are the Intelligence and Research Section
of the Italian SCP Foundation, a kind of Mobile
Task Force that investigates possible informational
leads.
Paolo and his team were given amnestic treatment
and any evidence they’d collected was scrubbed
from existence.
Meanwhile, lieutenant Marco Levini, leader
of the Mobile Task Force SSM-II squad, aka
“Legio Atlantidis”
was being dispatched to the source of the
problem, SCP-057-IT itself.
What started off as a relatively straightforward
exploratory mission soon took an extremely
strange turn.
Levini and his men reported activity down
in the underwater city, observing from the
safety of their armored Foundation submarine.
While the aquatic humanoids living in 057-IT
were undeniably the same species, their culture
seemed to be split up into two unique groups:
One group had thinner scales on their arms
and legs.
This group was more numerous, having at least
sixty active specimens, and was characterized
by their extreme aggression towards any outsiders.
As for the smaller group, they had thicker
scales, as well as a number of eerily consistent
injuries to their hands, feet, and gills.
They were also distinct from the thin-scales
in terms of behavior, as they were a far friendlier,
more curious bunch.
At times, members of this subset would approach
the submarine and regard it with detached
fascination.
Sometimes, they would even point at the submarine
and laugh, though their reasons for doing
this are unknown.
Eventually, Lieutenant Levini was so confident
in their safety around the merpeople that
he and a few other team members decided to
disembark from the submarine on a diving excursion
and properly explore the aquatic city below.
This would prove to be a dangerous tactical
error on Levini’s part.
During what seemed like a routine exploratory
mission, Levini was ambushed by a squadron
of thin-scales, grabbed from behind, and kidnapped.
He was taken as a hostage and spirited away
into one of the city’s various buildings,
where a thick-scale known as Laetitia acted
as his warden.
But Levini soon found out that being under
Laetitia’s care was a profoundly lucky turn
of events on his part, both because it allowed
him to learn more about the situation and
because she was one of the small group left
in the city who hadn’t become dangerous
fanatics.
That’s right: The merpeople were in the
middle of a heated civil war.
Both from the observations of Levini during
his captivity, and later interviews conducted
by project head Dr. Giuseppe Pistillo with
some liberated members of the thick-scales,
they learned that a terrible religious conflict
had broken out in SCP-057-IT.
The accounts coming from the rescued citizens
illustrated a similar backstory to what the
Italian Foundation had theorized regarding
the merpeople: They were the descendants of
peoples that lived on the island of Nisyros
up to the 14th century BCE before it was devastated
by a volcanic eruption, forcing them into
the ocean, where they evolved the ability
to live in aquatic environments through anomalous
means.
Since this change, this new species has been
operating in Mediterranean waters, migrating
regularly in order to avoid detection, passing
their way of life from generation to generation
as the world changed and shifted above them.
In many ways, they were quite similar to humans,
such as their reproductive habits - they mate
and reproduce after a gestation period, more
like mammals than fish, though their gestation
period is slightly shorter than human beings
at six months.
They largely speak Latin, though the oldest
merperson among them also speaks Ancient Greek.
Merchildren born in Foundation containment
have shown strong language acquisition skills,
as they have proven more than able to learn
modern Italian.
And even more fascinating from a standpoint
of sociological study, the merpeople have
formed their own unique culture under the
sea.
And this is where the problems started.
Abstaining from the belief of the Greek and
Roman pantheons their ancestors looked up
to, the merpeople instead worshipped their
own group of water-bound deities, whose images
were reflected in the great statues in the
center of the town.
The large building near the statues and the
chasm was the home of the “mayor”, the
town’s de facto leader.
However, what had been a workable system for
centuries began falling to ruin when a strange
religious fanaticism began to spread.
A cult-like group soon formed and began holding
ceremonies where they worshipped a powerful
entity in the chasm known as The Great Eye.
This new cult was known as the Cult of The
Great Eye of the Mediterranean, or CGEM for
short.
What began as a fringe belief soon became
a frenzy and took over the better part of
the town, with the Acolytes of the Great Eye
proving themselves more than willing to spread
the gospel of their new deity with violence.
Some of the more ardent non-believers were
killed for their heresy, while others were
simply ritualistically mutilated in order
to prevent them from rebelling.
Laetitia had her own evidence of these targeted
mutilations.
The thin-scales had cut the aquatic webbing
from between her fingers and toes, making
it harder for her to swim away and escape.
Other suspected heretics were given the same
treatment.
The reason that the thick-scales even had
thicker scales was that they stole forbidden
technology from the mayor to increase the
strength of their scales, hoping it would
help them better withstand the torments of
the Acolytes.
Those involved in the stealing of this technology
were captured and summarily executed for their
acts of defiance.
In a sense, Laetitia was protecting Levini
by advising him against trying to escape,
knowing the Acolytes of the Great Eye would
kill him if he did.
She knew that the only opportunity for escape
would come during the ceremony held by the
Acolytes to honor their frightening master.
When the day eventually came, as Levini was
running low on everything from food to oxygen,
everyone in the town was forced out into the
town center to witness the ritual.
The Acolytes gathered around the chasm and
began to chant in a frightening, unknown language.
As they chanted, a blinding light began to
emanate from the chasm, and as blurry shapes
emerged, nightmarish, tentacled gastropods
soon began to take form.
Truly Lovecraftian undersea monsters.
Shortly after the ritual, Levini and the thick-scales
were able to make a break for it, pursued
by the Acolytes of the Great Eye.
It was a close one, but thankfully, due to
the intervention and assistance of a trained
Mobile Task Force, the fanatical forces of
the Acolytes were repelled and the fleeing
merpeople, along with Levini, were rescued.
A number of thick-scales are now willingly
confined at Site Nettuno, an Italian Foundation
containment site, where they have undergone
numerous interviews with Foundation staff.
Incidentally, among them is the oldest merperson
previously present in SCP-057-IT, the only
one who spoke Ancient Greek fluently.
He was different from the others.
Extremely different.
In fact, he was a deity made into flesh, one
of the deities replaced by the worshippers
of the Great Eye.
This unfortunate former God had done everything
to keep his people’s lives safe and peaceful,
but in spite of his wisdom and best efforts,
Hell had once again broken loose.
Not everything is all well and good in SCP-057-IT.
Even if a human’s body changes, their nature
does not, and the worst parts of human nature
seemingly followed these unfortunate merpeople
into what should have been their paradise
under the sea.
But all hope isn’t lost.
If you were to judge the entire human race
on one community in turmoil, you probably
wouldn’t leave with a very favorable impression
of us, either.
Correspondence with a French branch of the
SCP Foundation reveals that mercreatures aren’t
just localized to one warring underwater city
in Sardinia.
Mermaids have also been discovered and confirmed
by Foundation field agents off of the coast
of France.
Eighty percent of the Ocean still remains
unmapped to this day.
Who knows what else is out there, just waiting
to be found?
Now go check out “The Horror of Body Stealing
Rain - SCP-3300” and “SCP-1861 - The Crew
of the HMS Wintersheimer” for more water-based
horrors from the SCP Foundation!